like you we were all saddened to hear
the news of alex trebek's passing
yesterday at the age of 80
after a battle with pancreatic cancer
now we had the honor to sit down with
her back twice last year
including this reflective interview from
september 2019
when alex talked about his fight with
cancer his deep appreciation for the
outpouring of support
and how a home improvement project took
on a higher meaning
here is the story as it aired last year
and now here is the host of jeopardy
alex alex trebek has been a comforting
witty and eloquent presence in our
living rooms as the host of jeopardy
for three and a half decades we are now
dealing with world landmarks players and
here comes your clue
we first heard the news in march that
trebek is battling stage four
pancreatic cancer now normally the
prognosis for this
is not very encouraging but i'm going to
fight this
i'm on the mend and
after an initial encouraging response to
treatment this announcement was released
in mid-september
this past summer because i was making
such good progress
we thought i was finished with chemo
that was a bit
premature and certainly over optimistic
trebek's numbers went south and it
happened quickly
the doctors are now re-examining my
situation and it appears i will be
having
more chemo treatments ahead of me i had
the honor to sit down with alex the day
of that announcement
he was forthright in talking about what
he's going through
explaining his seemingly indefatigable
response
in his battle against cancer there's
nothing
that i could do about my situation
that i'm not doing i'm following the
doctor's recommendations
during treatment trebek will continue to
host jeopardy first here are the
categories in double jeopardy
hip-hop musicians real names
he says he considers himself lucky he
referenced his age of 79
saying he's lived a good life and added
that others fighting cancer
have it more difficult some of them are
suffering in pain
yes some of them become addicted to
opioids because of the pain they're
enduring
i don't have that except on
rare and fleeting occasions may be
surprising for someone
directly in the spotlight for decades
but his outlook
often circles back to putting others
first including
reflecting on how cancer impacts his
family
don't let yourself get down too much
because
not only does it affect you but it
affects the people
around you and that's probably the
toughest part dealing
with the people who are close to you
your loved ones because
you're trying to not complain you're
trying not to put too much pressure on
them
you realize that you're short with them
sometimes
for no reason whatsoever that you can
explain and it's unfair to them
i wondered if he was aware of how the
way he's handled his diagnosis
with such optimism and courage even
vulnerability
has inspired others in their own fight i
don't feel that
i'm a great inspiration your reaction to
it
has inspired them so it's really it's
well
whether or not you know you're doing it
you really are and that's that's a good
thing
and i thank you for viewing me in that
way i have to ask about these home
projects
alex told me a story about how a
mainline water leak at his house
provided an unforeseen victory
trebek handyman on the home front had
water shooting
feet in the air i told my wife i said i
felt really good about
being able to do this sure because i've
been feeling very very
weak i have trouble going upstairs
and it just it was so satisfying
and to be able to do work like that
around the house if you care for your
home
and you take pride in your home and
you are one of those individuals who
when something goes wrong
wants to fix it immediately then these
are the kinds of things that bring
tremendous satisfaction
and i love it he's still smiling still
hosting
still fixing leaks thank you for that
information of course
we add to our information stash here in
jeopardy all the time
facing stage four cancer alex trebek has
chosen a path of positivity
his television appearances broke ratings
records in las vegas oh easy one who is
brian loftis
sorry and for others facing their own
great challenge
he imparts a powerful message i want to
be a positive
influence in terms of the message i send
them
and that is that hey stay the course
yes keep your chin up you never know
things have a way of turning quickly in
in relation to cancer one week from now
they may have a cure and maybe the
miracle
is in the message in addition to
entertaining us for nearly four decades
alex trebek also showed us how to face
adversity
with perspective humor and consistent
courage
trebek's final 35 episodes will air as
they were shot
you can see them right here on channel 8
weeknights at 7 00.
the jeopardy team has always been so
kind to us and we at eight news now
extend
our deepest sympathies to all of them
denise kirsten
truly alex trebek one of a kind yes
indeed and i believe he worked up until
a week and a half ago didn't he
such strength such courage really
incredible the way he's lived the last
year and a half
with this and so inspiring to so many as
cancer has really touched all of our
families in some way
right he was so brave i mean to continue
to working to what 10 days ago
wow good for him we're going to miss him
for sure we certainly are